good morning Hank it's Monday and uh
you're gonna die
you're gonna die and I'm gonna die and
everyone we've ever loved is gonna die
and then one day there will be no one
left to remember that anyone ever did
anything and because there will be no
one left to remember the books we wrote
or the World Cups we won or the
mathematical proofs we proved or the in
your pants jokes we made someday it will
be as if those things never happened
Hank I remember one time when I was at
the planetarium at the Orlando Science
Center when we were kids and they
explained that at about 6 billion years
or whatever the earth is gonna fall into
the Sun or some I don't remember I'm not
good at science but anyways the first
time I ever had to grapple with the fact
that the habitability of the universe
itself is temporary and asked the
question about an my teacher was like ah
but it's a long way away and I thought
well it seems like a long way away to
you teacher because you're old I'm eight
it's very plausible that with advances
in medical science I could live for 6
billion years now some people seem to
think that talking about death or
endings or the inevitable temporariness
of the entire human experiment is
somehow pessimistic or nihilistic but
Hank I thought your video in Friday
which so brilliantly explored games and
losing and non-attachment was actually
quite optimistic what you wanted on your
video is that what we don't get to
choose whether we're going to lose the
games we play we do get to choose which
games those are we don't get to choose
whether to care but we do get to choose
what to care about and when I find
myself caring about a game I like to be
challenged to think about whether that
game helps the people who are here with
me now whether it honors those who came
before me and whether it paves the way
for those who come after me because all
this is temporary but we have a say in
how temporary it is another way somebody
gave me an anglerfish it's cute right I
choose nerdfighting and I choose books
and yes even though it's silly
I choose the World Cup because it
transcends geography and ethnicity and
wealth and politics and puts the world
where we belong playing on the same
grass with the same ball actually
dumbass it takes more than one ball to
play a World Cup soccer match yeah I
realized that but if I had said playing
with the same balls you would have been
like hey hey hey
he said playing with balls that's right
I would have by the way who's the lucky
guy who gets to have the pair of balls
that the whole world place would shut up
mr. filthy pants I'm trying to make a
point here so Hank your brilliant video
on Friday did not make me change my mind
about whether to watch the World Cup but
it did force me to think about why
care about soccer and it also reminded
me that caring is a choice and I'm
grateful to you for that so grateful in
fact that you have inspired me to make a
world cup episode of truth or fail in
the hopes that by sharing my world cup
knowledge with you I might turn you into
a football fan so Hank don't forget to
be awesome I will see you on Wednesday
and here's truth or fail hi there you're
watching the World Cup edition of truth
or fail YouTube's only game show and I
am watching Spain place Switzerland
sorry but I've watched every single
World Cup match since 1994 and I am NOT
going to let this edition of truth or
fail break my streak here's how the game
works I'm going to tell you two
purported facts and you're either going
to click on the true one or you're going
to click on the wrong one and fail worse
than England at a World Cup penalty
shootout here's your first set of facts
fact 1 the goalie United States scored
against England and the so called
miracle on grass the 1950 World Cup was
in fact not scored by an American but by
a Haitian or fact 2 the term soccer is
derived from the fact that early
football players often played not in
cleats but in their socks